today on the matt walsh show louden
county continues to lie about and cover
up the sexual assault of a student
inside the girl's bathroom by a boy in a
dress but loudoun county is not an
outlier that's what we have to
understand there has been a sex abuse
epidemic in public schools for decades
we'll talk about that today also an mba
star will not be allowed to play for his
team because he refuses to get
vaccinated and bill de blasio removes a
statue of thomas jefferson plus
republicans remain mostly silent about
the buying administration's plan to
monitor our bank accounts and demi
lovato continues to speak out about her
alien encounters and our daily
cancellation has the remake craze over
at disney finally gone too far well
we'll discuss that and much more today
on the matt wall show
[Applause]
[Music]
as you've heard by now on this show and
from the daily wires reporting the
loudoun county school board is the
subject of national attention and
righteous outrage after the school
system tried to cover up the rape of a
female student inside the girls bathroom
by a boy in a dress
during school hours
alleged
loudoun county wanted to keep the
incident out of public view in large
part because it was at the same time
pushing through a policy that would open
up girls bathrooms across the district
and allow boys to enter if they claim to
identify as girls
the you know this this incident was very
inconvenient for that agenda and so
that's one of the main reasons
we can assume why they wanted to cover
it up the superintendent in loudoun
county scott ziegler went so far as to
outright deny on the record that any
rape in any bathroom had occurred in his
district this was weeks after one had
actually occurred allegedly
and he made this claim again weeks after
this rape in which in which the victim
was among other things forcibly
sodomized i mean this was a brutal
violent rape as any rape is
so it was this denial issued by the
superintendent at a school board meeting
in june
that um
sent the victim's father scott smith
into a rage understandably which led to
his arrest and to him becoming the
media's poster child for violent parents
quote unquote violent parents at school
board meetings who now require fbi
monitoring of course nobody in the media
ever mentioned why scott smith was so
enraged that was left out of the story
completely until the daily wire stepped
in
and we now know also to make matters
worse that there was another rape of a
girl in a loudoun county school building
after the rape in the bathroom and this
second rape was according to reports
committed by the same male student or at
least a male student with the same name
so you can connect the dots
the school system allegedly then let him
back into a school
after the first rape where he proceeded
to brutalize another girl
but none of these revelations
and or or the spotlight being shown on
this issue has caused the school board
to abandon its lies and finally tell the
truth on the contrary they issued
another statement yesterday and here's
what the new statement says in part
it says school board members are
typically not given details of
disciplinary matters the board may be
obligated to consider long-term
suspensions or expulsions and must
ensure that students have not been
deprived of due process consequently
members of the school board were not
aware of the specific details of this
incident until it was reported in media
outlets earlier this week
okay so that's that's their excuse for
publicly denying that any rape had
happened
they are now claiming they're actually
claiming that they didn't know about
this until the daily wire told them
about it this week
they want us to believe that a girl was
sodomized in a bathroom during school
hours in one of their schools and they
didn't know about it
until an outlet stationed in nashville
reported on it five months later
well that's clearly bogus it's a lie
it's an insult
and they tell these lies while hiding
from the public not allowing the public
into the public meetings
now only giving parents 60 seconds to
take them to task for their evil
criminal behavior
this whole thing is unconscionable but
let's not make the mistake of thinking
that the loudoun county situation
because it's so egregious is therefore
an outlier it is not
okay there has been an epidemic of this
kind of thing sexual assaults and
cover-ups in our public school system
for decades now
decades
our schools are crawling
with sex predators
a study commissioned by the department
of education found that one in 10 public
school students are quote targets of
sexual misconduct and that's just by the
teachers so that works out to over 4
million victims
and out of that number 3 million have
experienced actual sexual assault
according to the department of
education's own report
the epidemic in our schools is 100 times
worse than the scandal in the catholic
church though it's probably gotten about
100 times less attention
and these are numbers from that was a
report that was done in uh you know i
want to say
2004 or so
decade and a half ago do we imagine that
the situation has improved or
since then or or has it deteriorated i
mean does does institutional sexual
abuse generally clear itself up if
ignored or does it continue to get worse
and that again is only abused by
teachers
abuse by students of other students is
its own crisis in a 2017 report the ap
found seventeen thousand cases
of student on student abuse in a
four-year period seventeen thousand
many of the stories are downright
horrific both boys and girls harassed
assaulted raped sodomized
the schools have done a manifestly and
nearly universal terrible job
of
handling these cases and sometimes they
cover it up as they did in loudoun
county
you know they'll sometimes
send abusers whether students or
teachers to other schools moving people
around
the same kind of thing that we see when
there are these institutional sexual
abuse epidemics and cover-ups
but what else can we expect i mean there
are hundreds of deviants and perverts
working in the system
we can't very well depend on them to
police the conduct of their students
when they can't police their own conduct
now the loudoun county school board had
a special incentive to cover up and lie
about this case because they were trying
to protect the trans agenda an agenda
that they put before all other concerns
including the safety of students i mean
far far above the safety of students in
fact
most of these other cases were covered
up for other reasons um and i don't want
to distract from the way that the
loudoun county story intersects with the
trans agenda and how the trans agenda
sets the stage for this assault and for
many more to come by allowing boys into
the girls bathroom
and and when it comes to assaults
enabled by the trans agenda loudoun
county also isn't an outlier there
we know about the we spa case where a
sex predator male was able to access the
female locker room and expose his erect
penis to women and girls
we know about cases in prison where
female prisoners have been allegedly
raped sometimes impregnated
with the woman identifying males they're
locked up with
as far as the prisons go
i think it's very likely that there is a
a whole a whole separate epidemic
happening there and we just don't know
about it
because these victims have no way of
telling us
we're entirely dependent upon the system
to let us know that these things are
happening and they're not going to tell
us
so we don't want to lose sight of any of
that or distract from it but my point is
that as far as covering up sexual
assaults on a public school campus go
this story fits into a larger
long-standing standing pattern
this kind of thing has been happening
for many many years not always in
bathrooms of course often in classrooms
or elsewhere on school grounds
or in a teacher's home or in their car
and the thing that ties all these cases
together
is that the system's first instinct is
to protect itself to protect its own
interests and its own agenda
protecting children is far down the list
of priorities if it makes the list at
all which i don't think it does in fact
the system itself
sexualizes and abuses kids it's part of
the curriculum they put pornographic
material in school libraries they teach
middle schoolers about masturbation and
anal sex during sex ed they push gender
fluidity and cross-dressing is it any
wonder that the people behind all of
this are not too eager to stamp out the
physical sexual abuse of children
would rather cover it up than expose it
the school system is again run by amoral
deviants and child sex predators
all of what we're seeing in loudoun
county across the country is a result of
that
they view your children not as people
but objects sexual objects
so we can't really be surprised by these
results
but at least
it seems parents are finally beginning
to care about this problem i can tell
you that i've been shouting
from the rooftops about the sexual abuse
epidemic in schools for years now
and the response mostly has been a giant
collective yawn from the public
it's been sort of amazing and incredibly
frustrating to see that
you know to sit here and say
by the way there's an epidemic of sexual
abuse in the school system that the
department of education has even told us
about
maybe we should do something about this
and most
people that hear you say that go oh
man there are other things to talk about
people would rather talk about the
sexual abuse problems in hollywood
or in catholic churches 30 years ago
than discuss what's happening right now
today in the schools their own children
attend
that's the way it has been
but that dynamic seems to finally be
changing parents are awake and paying
attention for the first time in many
cases
and that's the good news
and let's keep that up
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know a lot of people get nervous
when the topic of abortion comes up a
lot of pro-lifers do i even though we
are standing
in the truth and uh we know what's right
and our position is
very simple and seemingly
self-explanatory you know don't kill
innocent people that's our position
don't kill children that's our position
even despite that it makes people
nervous because there are so many
different arguments that get thrown at
you from the other side from all
different directions and that's why you
need a book
like 40 days for life's new book what to
say when the complete new guide to
discussing abortion
since its release it's already been a
number one amazon new release and a
number two amazon bestseller and it's
already on its second printing as well
and that's because it is a really
effective book and incredibly easy to
use it tells you what to say what not to
say
and the proven arguments that uh have
worked for everybody including planned
parenthood and abortion workers the 220
plus of them have been converted by 40
days for life because of arguments like
this so what to say when the complete
new guide to discussing abortion how to
change minds and convert hearts in a
brave new world is available now you can
get it on amazon or directly from 40
days for life at 40daysforlife.com
all right so i'm uh i'm trying to make
it through here you know i had hoped to
be more rested today i was intent on
catching up on some sleep last night but
that plan was foiled when our
four-year-old came into the room at
about one in the morning because he had
a bad dream
and now you know my my wife is nicer in
these situations than i am
and it's not that i'm mean you know i do
take it seriously i try to con
when there's a bad dream situation and
i'm on the hook for it i try to console
the dream victim
especially because kids really do have
terrifying dreams
if you ever listen to them describe
their dreams it's like something out of
a horror movie so like the other day my
again my four-year-old had a different
bedroom
and uh he told me about it
and he said that that in his dream
he heard something in the basement
and so he opened the door to the
basement and there was a man standing at
the bottom of the steps staring up like
silently not saying anything
and i said well who was the man in the
dream i mean maybe it was uh you know
maybe it was santa claus or something
coming to you know try to look at
try to try to see this in a positive
light
and he said uh well i don't know who the
man was daddy because he didn't have a
face
and i said wow that is yeah that's
terrifying i i am scared now actually
you're spreading the bad dream to me now
i'm infected
stop talking about it keep this to
yourself
so i get it with the dreams but um i saw
but i'll try to console the child and
then send them back to their own bed to
sleep or or i'll bring them back to the
bed i'll put them to bed and i'll say
good luck with the faceless guy i gotta
go back to bed
but my wife she'll always let the scared
child sleep in our bed
and that's what she did last night
so our four-year-old ended up in bed
with us
and if you know anything about young
children and how they sleep you know how
this goes
like they little kids when they sleep
they're like wind-up toys that are still
wound up
but knocked over on their sides so their
legs and their arms are still flailing
around so this kid is thrashing all over
the bed all night he's like pummeling me
in the side of the face
karate chopping me kicking me dropping
elbows
i felt like i was trying to take a nap
in the middle of a mosh pit or something
meanwhile the kid he's he's drooling all
over the pillows and then
morning finally comes
and you as the parent you're like a
zombie sleepless battered broken
and the kid bounds out of bed full of
energy
well-rested
that's the way it goes
all right so let's start with this uh
brooklyn netstar kyrie irving has been
banned by his team from playing because
he refuses to comply
with new york's vaccine mandate
and he has explained what his reasoning
is he says he's not
anti-vax in general he just believes
that he should have the right to
determine
what sorts of substances he puts into
his body
uh
really reasonable position i would say
here he is explaining it on instagram
live listen
i'm always going to stay true
to me and that's me you know this is my
life i get to do whatever i want with
this this is one body that i get here
one god body that i get here
and you telling me what to do with my
body and it has nothing to do with the
organization i'm gonna put that out
there has nothing to do with the nets it
has nothing to do with my teammates this
has everything to do with what's going
on in our world and i'm being grouped in
to something that's bigger than than
just the game of basketball and you know
you got that
that fandom you know which is like a
religion to people out here basketball
is like a religion entertainment's like
a religion of people they like get so
caught up emotionally it's just like yo
effin get vaccinated or just leave you
know we angry at what you're doing man
it's just like not us
like what are you talking about i'm a
human being
i have emotions
i have feelings i have thoughts
uh things that i keep to myself things
that i share
but i'm staying grounded in what i
believe in
it's just as simple as that it's not
about being anti-vaxxed
or about being uh you know on one side
or the other like it's just really about
being true to what feels good for me
uh you know i'm still uncertain about a
lot of things that and that's okay
you know if i'm gonna be demonized for
having more questions and taking my time
to make a decision with my life then
that's just what it is
pretty reasonable
to any reasonable person that would seem
reasonable at least
and who is he putting at risk exactly
you know we come back to this same
question
if everybody else
is obediently complying and they're all
getting vaccinated
who who who is he going to infect
we're worried about him infecting one of
the other players on the basketball
court
they're all young
extremely healthy and physically fit
males
and everybody else is vaccinated
so what's the concern exactly
why do we have to force this on him well
because because it is it's about the
forcing
it's about it's about compliance
now um
sports media you know usually when a
an athlete basketball player
is taking some sort of stand
um and they're punished for it
by the team
you know usually sports media
is
there to come to their defense well
maybe i shouldn't say it usually it
really really depends on what the stand
is and what what this is all about um
one of the primary examples that comes
to mind of course is colin kaepernick
now we can't even say that colin
kaepernick colin kaepernick was not
actually punished by the league he was
he was never banned from playing
but he decided he wanted to take his own
stand
and um
then he wasn't able to get another job
in the nfl the reason for that is that
you know while kyrie irving is still one
of those top stars in in basketball and
they're not even letting him play
colin kaepernick by the side by the time
he had discovered his passion for social
justice had his play had already he had
gone from mediocre to terrible already
he wasn't worth the headache
and that's why he's not playing the
league and also he doesn't he doesn't
want to play he doesn't he actually
doesn't want to play because he can make
a lot more money and be a lot more
famous as a professional victim
but
sports media very quick to come to
kaepernick's defense
even though
what what is he actually taking a stand
against
he's taking a stand against an imaginary
issue
this imaginary problem of systemic
racism and cops hunting black people
that's not really happening
but this infringement on basic liberty
with places like new york trying to
force the substance of people into into
people's bodies that's actually
happening
and here's what's let's find out what
sports media what they have to say about
kyrie irving here's a stephen a smith
and and uh prominent commentator
especially when it comes to basketball
and here's what he has to say in uh
about this let's listen
the brooklyn nets need to get rid of
kyrie irving he got the gun
it's just a problem he's just a problem
i want to put everything in this proper
perspective keyshawn kendrick molly
there's a whole bunch of people out here
myself included maybe not you key but a
lot of us that have reservations about
taking the vaccine i understood it but
we took it yes
not just because of us
but because of the people that we were
going to be around
and more importantly the obligations
that we have
i don't get vaccinated i can't do first
take i don't give i'll do first take i'm
leaving everybody stranded not to
mention compromising my own bankroll and
bottom line which i was not going to do
let me be very very clear about that
okay i apologize for that to a damn soul
all right that's how i roll okay having
said all of that
even if that were not the case
if i'm a member of a team
and we've aligned
and we're mission minded i'm not going
to be the one to jump off the train to
compromise the mission okay i'm going to
be the one that stands that stands pat
and he's like yo that's what we doing
that's what we got to do
kevin durant 6.2 billion plus people
have taken a vaccine whatever conspiracy
kyrie irving wants to come up with all
right good luck with that but the bottom
line is that means you're looking at
everybody else who's taking the vaccine
and that's the position that you're
maintaining people out there who don't
want to take the vaccine that's your
personal choice i get where you're
coming from with that but you evidently
ain't a part of a team
i i every time i listen to this guy i
don't i don't know how i mean that was a
minute that's that's the most like it
possibly there are people who
i guess he has multiple shows and people
sit down to listen to him on purpose
i can't imagine why it's like it's like
it's like human whoopee cushion that
you're listening to and
first of all 6.2 billion people are
vaccinated
no they're not that's almost the entire
population of the globe
i think the actual number of fully
vaccinated people is something like 3
billion
still still quite a lot but you know
he's only got he's only doubled it
and and but but what he says there at
the very beginning oh they got to get
they got to get rid of him he's got to
be gone
can you if someone had said that
if someone had gone on espn or one of
these other sports channels
and said that about
colin kaepernick we just got to get rid
of him he's not he's in trouble yeah
he's not worth the trouble
um stephen a smith would be one of the
first to call that person racist
even though colin kaepernick is like
half black
kyrie irving is far blacker than colin
kaepernick is
and in this case you know colin
kaepernick is protesting nothing i mean
his rights are not being infringed upon
by anybody
and he wasn't banned from the league or
banned from anything
kyrie irving is speaking out against the
actual infringement on our basic human
liberties to decide what substances put
into our bodies
and then pretending that it's not just
about you it's about the team it's about
your responsibilities
and of course he admits in the middle of
it that okay actually i'm only worried
about my own bottom line because it's
all i care about
that's the real answer
but you're doing it for other people
no you you don't
we can we cannot allow them to get away
with with flipping this around like this
you don't get vaccinated for the fact
what what what is supposed to protect
you is your vaccine that's what's
supposed to protect you not kyrie
irving's vaccine but your own
and if it doesn't protect you then why
should kyrie irving get it
either it protects you or it doesn't
if it doesn't then you have no right to
sit there and no basis
to make the argument
for anyone else getting it if you don't
believe that it actually protects you
all right let's move next to uh
this from the daily wire says new york
city mayor bill de blasio is removing
removing a statue of thomas jefferson
the third president united states and a
founding father from city hall after
nearly two centuries
new york city's public design commission
each
member of which is appointed by the
mayor
is planning to loan the jefferson
statute to the new york historical
society
the commission has listed the statute
loan under its consent agenda meaning
the decision to remove the statute would
not be open for public debate
um
and uh let's see do they even democratic
councilwoman debbie rose said last year
that jefferson's ownership of slaves
justifies his bus expulsion from city
hall
she said in june 2020
his words are all men are created equal
but they were not matched by his action
which included the ability to sell by
mortgage and lease human beings
yeah it's it's true that um
that thomas jefferson
you know in the in the in the late uh
18th century early 19th century
did not fully uh while he said all all
men are created equal
he didn't fully live by that that's true
he was not he was not he was not he was
not perfect it turns out
um
but do you know who else
at that point in history
didn't fully live by
the notion that all men are created
equal
and didn't fully believe it do you know
do you know who else falls into that
category
uh well just like everybody else on
earth at that point
everybody else on earth
i mean slavery was of course widespread
across the globe at that time
especially in non-western countries
what makes the west unique in their
relationship with slavery
is that the west was was the first to
abolish it
was the first to realize that there's
something wrong with it
but wherever people stood on slavery
was was there anyone in jefferson's time
who would be considered racially
enlightened by our standards today
could you go back in time to the year i
don't know 1800
go anywhere on earth
anywhere and talk to anyone on the
subject of race
if you were to do that go anywhere on
earth in the year 1800 and talk to
anyone on the subject of race would
would you be able to find a single soul
on earth
who would not be racist by our standards
today
no you wouldn't
not one
so this is of course the the war in
american history which uh as we've
talked about was always destined to go
beyond
uh you know we were told out we're just
taking down confederate statues and then
and then it was yeah well we're gonna
throw columbus in there too because he
was uh he was as bad as hitler hey it'll
stop there it'll stop there
no it will never stop
and uh and i don't think it's gonna stop
with
it starts with all of the white
historical
figures and by historical figures i mean
we mean any white person born before i
don't know the year
1990
um it starts with them i don't even
think it ends with uh with with just the
white people
i've been predicting for a while and i
still predict that i mean i'd say we're
maybe i don't know three to four years
out
maybe five years from the uh from when
from martin luther king jr gets canceled
that that'll happen
uh he wasn't white so that buys him a
little bit of time
but he was a male
and we do know that
there's plenty of evidence to suggest
that he was
not exactly always respectful of women
in fact there are credible allegations
that he was
involved in the in the abuse of
women so they'll get around to him i'll
get around to everybody
um
as we say columbus obviously was uh is
he's already long since been canceled
but more from the war on american
history camila harris spoke at the
national congress of american indians
it's their 78th annual convention this
is on tuesday
and she just had once she began of
course
as they must with one long apology for
american history and here's what that
sounded like
since
1934
every october the united states has
recognized the voyage of the european
explorers who first landed on the shores
of the americas
but that is not the whole story
that has never
been the whole story
those explorers
ushered in a wave of devastation for
tribal nations
perpetrating violence
stealing land
and spreading disease
we must not shy away
from this shameful past
and we must shed light on it
and do everything we can to address the
impact of the past
on native communities today
yeah those dastardly european explorers
those bastards
bringing civilization to this part of
the globe
how dare they
yeah we ought to apologize for that we
really should
uh just like we should and and and
frankly as as a white man
um i would like to apologize for
all of the deeds of uh white western men
because white western men have done a
lot of terrible things including
bringing civilization to this part of
the globe you know
i guess they they never should have come
i guess that's the uh the stance people
like camila harris they never should
have come
civilization should have should have
stopped
should have stopped dead on the other
side of the atlantic and and never
traveled across
no and then it'd be a utopia here
the indigenous tribes were 3 000 years
behind
you know but behind behind
civilization
and it should have been able to
it should it should have stayed that way
where you've got one side of the globe
advancing and everything and then this
entire part of the globe is just left
to be in the stone age that that's
that's what should have happened right
so we should apologize but i think also
as a white western man i should
apologize for
you know modern medicine
apologize for science for space travel
for electricity for air conditioning for
democracy for automobiles for airplanes
for human rights for computers for
plumbing for the printing press
all of those terrible deeds of white
western men i apologize for all of that
but
um
i want to make one other point about
this
because
you know one of the other problems here
with all of this constant apologizing
and the way that this clash of
civilizations
european versus uh
the the you know indigenous tribes
one of the other problems with the way
that it's presented
is that
yeah we've talked about how the
europeans are turned into these
cartoonish
villains in this black and white
scenario
but also we make the indian tribes
into these sort of lame
victims
when when really they weren't
uh yeah in in terms of technological
advancement and uh and you know
philosophy and government and in every
other way they were far behind
most of the rest of the world
but even so
i mean take take for example the
comanche tribe just just said just as
one example one of the tribes of the
great great plains
um and there was a i've told you before
about a great book written by the author
s c gwen who has
several really good history books
including one about stonewall jackson
called rebel yell that you should read
but he wrote a book called empire of the
summer moon
and this is about the comanche tribe not
focusing primarily on the indian wards
which were not in columbus time of
course this was in the in the
mid to late 19th century but the
comanche tribe
very impressive
and a very oppressive and interesting
history
you know they were they were masters of
the horse the spanish broad i mean the
horses horses are not indigenous to this
part of the globe
so the indian tribes didn't have them
until the spanish brought them over in
the the 16th century
and that just revolutionized
so many things
among the indian tribes and the
comanches many of the tribes in the
great plains became masters of the horse
even more so than than than the
europeans comanches especially
what they were able to do with a horse
riding bareback on the horses like
something out of you know it's something
out of an action film what they were
able to do
um
and they had this entire empire
but they were also a brutal
warfaring
violent people
and they struck terror in the the hearts
and and minds of other tribes around
them and also the the white settlers
whose settlements they would would often
raid and
murder everyone take a you know kidnap
and enslave people
um that's see that's that's part of the
story
but when you know
with the way that the indians are
presented
people like camille harris they don't
want to talk about that stuff they don't
want to tell you about the raids that
they would do the violence and
everything they want to leave all of
that out
but then in the process by by sanitizing
this history and by sanitizing these
people and their culture you end with
something that's just kind of
lame and uninteresting
you turn all the indian tribes into a
bunch of just these sort of like loser
victims
who were sitting around utterly helpless
until the year the big bad europeans
came in
and wiped them all out all at once
when in fact this was a violent clash of
civilizations that went on for centuries
and many of these indian tribes
especially the comanches and others were
more than able to hold their own for
quite a long time
because they knew how to wage war
because they'd been doing it for
centuries before the europeans came
so it is a it's a fascinating period of
history
with fascinating figures on both sides
of it
and uh and you just lose all that when
you when you try to sanitize it
all right let's uh move on nancy pelosi
was asked yesterday about this irs plan
which you've heard about on this show
because we've been talking about it uh
the the small little issue of the
vitamin d administration trying to
remove
and erase our financial um
freedom and privacy all together by
monitoring all of our bank accounts
almost all of our bank accounts it would
be something like 100 million bank
accounts they'd be monitoring uh that
have transactions of over six hundred
dollars nancy pelosi was asked about it
at a press conference here's what she
said
one of the pay fors in the buildback
better bill that's been proposed is irs
cracking down unpaid taxes banks are
starting to get calls from customers and
they're reporting these calls they're
concerned about this tracking of pay of
transactions that is greater than 600
um so americans are starting to be
worried about this do you think that
this pay for of giving the irs more
money to crack down on unpaid taxes
is going to stay in the reconciliation
yes
yes
yes yes well i i mean with all due
respect uh the plural of anecdote is not
data i've said that before here yes
there are concerns that some people have
but if people are breaking the law and
not paying their taxes one way to track
them is through the banking measure i
think 600 but that's a negotiation
that will go on as to what the amount is
but yes
600 so it's part of the negotiation but
she she thinks we need to find the high
income earners who are not paying their
taxes
and uh 600 is no negotiation maybe it'll
be 700
we're looking for the high income
earners so we're going to start in the
hundreds of dollars which again that's
100 million i think that's the number
that i saw
100 million households would be affected
by this
that's
100 million is that uh that's still the
top one percent hundred million
how many people are in this country
billions
no what's actually happening here here
is who is really being targeted
and and this is who they they really
must be looking for because if they were
actually looking
for the billionaires
then they would be
they'd be setting the threshold at
transactions of 60 000
in a month or something like that
um
but they're not and there's a reason for
that
and the real reason is that this is
their excuse to put the almost the
entire country under a permanent irs
audit
and to be able to track you know
everything we're doing all the money
that's coming in and out of our accounts
that's the real reason but but who are
they actually going to be finding i mean
uh who are the the so-called tax cheats
that
they're going to be primarily
um exposing here well it's gonna be
people in the you know in the in the in
the so-called gig economy right
waiters
um
landscapers
you know people who mow lawns
babysitters
it's going to be people like that
very much middle class
uh income-wise lower middle-class people
who get you know they they a lot of
times they get paid under the table
they make a lot of money off table they
don't they don't always declare
they get paid in cash they deposit it
doesn't always show up you know there's
there's not a there's not a w-2
for it
and um they're not always declaring it
as you know 1099 income and all that
kind of stuff
those are the people that are being
targeted
that's who they're fighting they're not
they're not they're not finding bill
gates here
that's not who they're going to be
bringing to justice they're bringing
your babysitter to justice here that's
what they're doing
which brings me to my next question
which is
where are the republicans on this
but i've heard
a few republicans speaking out
but how are they not all in one voice
crying out against this how is this not
the subject of immense
outrage
how is this not at least a subject of of
discussion even on the right
you know this is one of those issues
where i kind of feel like it's just like
with the sexual abuse epidemic in
schools i felt like i was talking to
brick wall for years i kind of feel the
same way here
i mean i can't be the only one who sees
this as a big big deal the vaccine
mandates are a big deal that's horrible
this is worse than that
okay we don't need to get into ranking
which is worse in terms of tyranny but
this is worse
this is the irs accessing your bank
account
without a warrant permanently
and republicans are just off twiddling
their thumbs
yeah they're they'll monitor the
situation just like the irs will be
monitoring our bank account soon enough
they're going to monitor the situation
and uh
you know once this policy is actually in
place then maybe they'll hold a hearing
about i think that's what they're
waiting for wait for the policy to be in
place and then they'll speak up against
it when there's nothing that can be done
about it
wait for the policy to be in place and
then when when
you know they run when during a
presidential election then the
republican presidents can campaign
against it
so that's what's going to happen this
policy will be put in place
but republicans won't really start
speaking out against it until you know
late 2023
right in time for the presidential
election
and another seamless transition here
speaking of presidential elections
here's a statement from president trump
that he just put out
of course he's banned from all social
media platforms so he has to sort of do
it it's he puts out statements which
which would have been his tweets if he
was allowed on twitter
and here's a statement he put out
yesterday it says if we don't solve the
presidential election fraud of 2020
which we have thoroughly and
conclusively documented republicans will
not be voting in 2022 or 24.
it is the single most important thing
for republicans to do
now
listen
um
i i believe republicans need to fight
it's what i was just talking about
but you also have to fight smart
and so any any time you're thinking
about okay here's a here's a battle plan
here's something we're going to do
as republicans as conservatives
then then you've got to think
um
how would the left feel about this
and so if you've got a battle plan in
mind and you're planning to do something
and the left would love it
that's probably not a good plan
and so for for president trump to be
encouraging people
to not vote in elections
we saw how that worked out in georgia
how does it work out you lose the senate
do you think so that was that was the
big plan in georgia we're not going to
the election's rigged we're not going to
vote we'll show you and the democrats
say
fantastic give us the senate
and then
how do we win there what what exactly is
the plan
and then you'll vote you don't vote in
2022 or 2024. what
that is a plan democrats love that
trump put this statement out and you
know who is sharing it on twitter the
democrats the left
they're the ones who made this statement
go viral they were saying yeah this is
fit this is an awesome idea i love it
you guys should definitely stay home
you're upset about uh about voter fraud
so yep stay home
if you have a plan in mind and you look
over and you see your enemies you know
rubbing their hands together licking
their lips and nodding their heads
hungrily um
it's it's a good indication that it's a
bad plan
see i'm all about fighting but how about
fighting smart we could also add that in
that's another thing maybe conservatives
can learn how to do fight smart use your
brain when you're fighting
you know think about what your opponents
would want you to do and do the opposite
of that
just an idea um
all right time to read the comments
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sorry i almost forgot i don't know how i
forgot but i i did in fact
forget
um demi lovato still speaking out about
about her alien encounters i gotta just
play this real quick and i'll read the
comments but um
uh i you know well let's let's play the
clipper this is this is her again she's
been she's been speaking recently about
her encounters with aliens and here she
is with kelly clarkson or kelly clarkson
show um again describing one of her
alien encounters and you know i just
find this really compelling listen
so i woke up in my room and there was
like three beings
and then and they
they were oh do you want to see your
planet and i was like
oh sorry
sorry you were like hell i was like hell
yeah let's go
so
i like whooshed out of my room and was
like hovering over the planet and then
all of a sudden they're like you want to
see our planet and i was like
hell yeah yeah
then i wish to this like pink and purple
planet that i've never seen
again i believe her
this is her truth and i validate it i
hear you i'm listening i believe you
demi lovato
um i believe all alien encounter stories
i think they're all true you know
and uh
but but
and i think this alien issue
it does create
you know um
strange bedfellows
i was looking for another expression i
could use here in this situation but
nothing came to mind so i'm going with
bedfellows with demi lovato it does
create that uh because now i you know i
don't think i'm aligned with her on any
other issue but on the alien issue i am
i will say though that i am concerned
that you know demi lovato has had
um several alien encounters apparently
according to her testimony which again i
totally believe
um i'm feeling number one i have to i
confess to feeling a little bit jealous
i've had zero encounters and i'm here
all the time talking about how much i
believe in the aliens and i'm on their
side with whatever plan they have they
want to take over the planet um you know
vaporize us whatever i'm on board for it
and i don't get to have any encounters
at all demi lovato gets all them i'm
trying not to be too focused on the
jealousy with that
but
putting my jealousy to the side i am i'm
a little concerned that
they they appear to have
zeroed in on her as sort of our leader
um and so demi lovato has become our our
diplomatic envoy to the extraterrestrial
beings and so i'm i'm worried about how
we're being represented
and when she tells me about these
conversations she's having with the
aliens where she's saying yeah i'm like
hell yeah i'll see your planet hell yeah
yeah yeah like
like let's go check out your planet i
and i it's just that's not
i just all i can say is i hope she's
she's taking this
role
seriously um
and i do kind of wish that the aliens
had chosen
someone else other than the non-binary
pansexual pop star
um
but
you know they have a plan
that i couldn't possibly understand all
right let's see
uh
well we'll start here it says
patrick says it's okay matt we and the
spg understand you even in silence well
i appreciate that
but i still am filled with uh with
with shame
and regret
for not acknowledging
the spg gang
on stage at the ryman but you know there
will be other live daily wire events and
i could promise you i can promise you
that that
i will not make that mistake again
um
and the other thing i did love about
that by the way is all the people who
were wearing the sbg shirts and then we
were when they were going through the
receiving line at the at the meet and
greet
and so all the other guys were forced to
take many pictures with people wearing
these sweet baby gang t-shirts which
which i think is fantastic
um let's see miss the bandwagon says how
could these people not see themselves in
superman before he's an every man
he may have been born with every super
super power but he grew up as a normal
kid who wanted to fit in
and as he became an adult had to find a
use for his talents and he tries his
best to force
be a force for good on the earth and
that's what we all strive for if these
people can only relate to a superman
that kisses boys then i don't believe
they care about superman the character
at all well you know of course they
don't
they don't they don't that's the point
this sort of this whole representation
thing
they don't think that any character
should just be a character
they want every character to reflect
them in every detail when they're
watching every story
they want to see them they want it to be
like
looking in a mirror
because of this narcissism
but i have to say it you know
i'm opposed to turning superman gay but
at the same time
i do think he's
probably the lamest super hero of them
all
so i can't ultimately get that upset
about it
i'd be fine with just erasing superman
altogether
he's he's one of the the first tries
that kind of making a
superhero
he's a very primitive early version
and that's why they gave him you know
they gave him every single superpower
he's immortal nothing can kill him he
could shoot lasers of his eyes he can
fly he can
what should we call this guy uh s
super man he's a he's super he's a man
he's superman
i just think he does he doesn't have
quite the same nuance and everything
that uh that some of these other
superheroes do
so
uh let's see
il berto says now i'm being warned about
the dangerous climate change content
matt is presenting yeah youtube did slap
the show with a warning yesterday
because i was talking about superman and
how in the new superman comic
he's going to be fighting climate change
and i i expressed skepticism
that superman could actually fight
climate change because i wasn't sure
what that would actually like how does a
superhero physically battle climate
change and so i expressed skepticism not
even about climate change my skepticism
was about superman's
ability
to prevent
or or stop climate change and i got
slapped with with
with an advisory label from youtube for
that
because of my superman skepticism
uh let's see what else we got here uh
maximilian says matt when will the daily
wire begin making pg-13 films instead of
r-rated films
uh well i
i don't think we're going into it
[Music]
having in mind what kind of rating you
want the film to have i think the idea
here is uh to just tell stories that are
worth telling
that's what we want to do with the daily
wires tell stories that are worth
telling tell stories that
hollywood is not telling
and then
you you it'll have whatever rating is
required like whatever is required to
tell that story honestly and completely
that's going to be in the film and then
the rating will reflect that
so we certainly have not committed to
we're only going to put out r-rated
movies but not that i'm at all involved
in the conversations for what movies we
make in the first place but uh
but
i know that's not happening
but you do have to decide what in order
to tell this story
and to tell it the right way
you know what what is what's needed
and depending what the story is maybe
there might be violence there might even
be vulgarity
in order to tell it honestly
and then the rating will just reflect
that so i think i think that's the way
we're going about it thank god i can
tell you about the jordan harbinger show
once again like a drink of cool water
amid all the sludge that i am serving
you on this disgusting awful show of
mine um the jordan harbinger show that
is a real podcast and it's a podcast you
definitely need to check out since
you're a fan i can only assume of high
quality fascinating podcasts hosted by
interesting people the show covers such
a wide range of topics through weekly
interviews with heavy hitting guests and
there are a ton of episodes you'll find
interesting
like for example as episodes with
colonel oliver north and kobe bryant
there's an episode for everyone
no matter what you're into the show
covers stories like how a professional
art forger somehow made millions of
dollars while being chased by the feds
and the mafia
that is far more interesting than
anything i've talked about on this show
let's be totally honest about that the
podcast covers a lot but one constant is
his ability to pull useful pieces of
advice from his guests i promise you
you'll find something useful that you
can apply to your own life for a change
so we really enjoy this show and we
think you will as well there's just so
much there check out the jordan
harbinger show jordanharbinger.com
start for some episode recommendations
or search for the jordan harbinger show
that's h-a-r-b as in boy i n as nancy
g-e-r on apple podcast spotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts and
also
there's more not only do we have an
extremely successful showing of uh
backstage at the ryman this past tuesday
but we also dropped some extremely
exciting news the daily wire has several
new projects in the works that are going
to change the way you stream because
we're bringing you even more non-woke
content that you literally won't find
anywhere else i'm pleased to announce
that we officially dropped the teaser
trailer for shut-in which is daily
wire's first original production the
film follows a young mother who is
barricaded inside a pantry by her
violent ex-boyfriend and must use her
ingenuity to protect her two small
children from escalating danger while
finding an escape and we actually have a
clip of that which we're going to play
right now right now here's a 60-second
look into a thriller that you're not
going to want to miss
laney
i told you i need to see you at all
times do you understand me
well i'm going to take off tonight so
the kids can sleep most of the way well
i'm mostly done i just need to finish
cleaning out the pantry
[Music]
lady
lady
mommy someone's here
please let me out
oh my god
oh my god
[Music]
smell the weakness from here
uh
and we we played that
yeah we played that like we said at the
daily wire backstage and uh i got to say
i was i knew about this this movie but i
was not expecting it to be even as
intense as that so that's the one that
i'm looking forward to seeing and also
we want to share a message with you from
the fearless gina carano about her new
daily wire movie this is this is a
different one
terror on the prairie is what it's what
it's called and it just started
production this week take a look
hi daily wire members this is gina
carano i'm coming to you from the set of
terror on the prairie um we came up to
montana
and it is absolutely god's country we're
making new friends
we've attracted the most incredible cast
and crew and a hell of a director we're
gonna make a great
great movie um i'm in love with the
script i'm in love with the character
i'm living fantasy right now so um
i can't wait for you guys to see it
we're gonna work hard
after we announced our first project
this summer the hollywood union started
debating vaccine mandates forecast and
crew and i wasn't into that i don't
believe anybody gets to make your
medical choices for you and i'm not
willing to force maths and vaccines on
anyone else
thank you to all the daywire members you
guys have been an extended family uh
thank you to you know everybody for
making this possible without you i
i don't know where i'd be right now and
right now there's no other place i'd
rather be so
i hope everybody is doing well um keep
fighting stick together we got this
never give up it's a lot of stuff and
this is all coming to the daily wire in
2022 uh there's no better time for that
reason to join us now head to
dailywire.com subscribe and enter code
2022 for 25 off your membership that's
dailywire.com
subscribe code 2022
for 25 off a new daily wire membership
and stay tuned for more updates and new
content now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
today we cancel and not for the first
time not for the last disney as you know
disney has for a while now been
disgorging a steady stream of stale
warmed over reheated recycled content
the company's creative brain trust
convened several years ago and the head
guy over there said you know i've got an
idea you know all those really popular
movies we made in previous decades we're
gonna make those again
oh you mean we're gonna we're gonna make
movies inspired by those classic films
no no we're gonna we're gonna make those
same films again you mean like sequels
no no we're just gonna we're gonna take
those movies
and do them again exactly the same
and that was the end of the discussion
it had been the end because there
clearly hasn't been anything in the way
of
actual creative thought or deliberation
going into disney's recent output
um
they have simply taken the films they
made in the past and done them again
shot for shot making changes only where
modern pc sensitivities demand so the
latest in this slate of microwaved
leftovers is the home alone reboot the
new home alone which will be available
for streaming in november
appears to have taken the original which
which still exists by the way you still
watch it and recreated it almost exactly
except without any of the charm of the
original
never mind the total suspension of
disbelief required to watch a home alone
remake set in the year 2021 i mean the
original only worked because it happened
to have been made a few years before
cell phones became household items but
these days with cell phones the story
should be over in about 15 minutes
when the mom realizes oh he left our
side and just calls him
then again it was never clear why she
couldn't have just called him even in
the original film i don't remember how
they got around that any case
there's a trailer for this abomination
let's watch part of it
it was the night before christmas
vacation
and the fun was in full swing you split
our family onto two separate flights mom
that's please the family left for their
big vacation is that everyone the cars
are leaving now but forgot one little
thing mum
dad uncle blake
they don't even know i'm here
they don't even know i'm here
my mum and dad have gone to tokyo i'm
totally on my own
you do realize that my 10 year old son
is at home by himself you just assumed
max was on the other flight we didn't
take a census
we got reports of suspicious people
around 36 lincoln ave
i can't go to jail honey i wouldn't last
30 seconds in gen pop it's where fresh
fish get got nobody here is getting
got
and we're criminals i don't think so
so sorry i was wrong it's not exactly
the same as the original in this one uh
the kid has a british accent so
that's the big it's home alone but with
the that that's what they that's what
they said when they when they were in
their their brainstorming session this i
know what if what if
home alone
but with a british accent
brilliant also joe pesci's character has
been replaced by the most boring actress
in hollywood that's another change and
all the men in this new version appear
to be submissive dunces as well like i
said you have to adjust for modern pc
sensibilities though somehow the kid
remains both male and white which is
easily the most surprising thing disney
has done in 25 years
maybe they figured they already checked
the intersectional box by choosing an
overweight child for the role i'm not
sure now i want to make just three
points here about this
first
um the death of creativity in hollywood
actually does matter i mean it is a big
deal
you can tell quite a lot about a society
from its creative and artistic output
a thriving society is an artistic
society
when we as a people
have something to say when we are
striving towards something when we have
a sense of awe and wonder all of that
tends to be reflected in the art that we
produce as a culture
so what does it say about us that our
most popular films and shows are almost
all rehashes of what came before
or else there are franchises where the
exact same story is told over and over
again
where only the title and the timeline
changes
it says that we're decadent and bored
and empty just like the movies we watch
of course there are still good
worthwhile innovative stories being told
we're telling some of them ourselves
here at the daily wire as mentioned
but um we don't have the audience that
disney has
if you want to produce interesting art
these days you're gonna have to start
out on the fringes and kind of fight
your way in and it will be an uphill
battle all the way
which brings us to the second point
it's often said that the major studios
have run out of ideas ah they've run out
of ideas no they haven't there's no
scarcity of ideas
as long as the world is populated by
conscious self-aware beings there will
always be ideas
and even a few good ones
the problem is not a lack of ideas
within disney or with any in any of
these other studios
but an outright hostility to ideas
they haven't
looked for ideas and come up empty
they've rather exiled all of the bold
and unique ideas and the people who come
up with them
because ideas are risky ideas always
have a chance of offending people
ideas don't always translate into the
chosen artistic medium perfectly
a multi-billion dollar corporation like
disney has no use for such volatile and
hazardous things as ideas
they'd rather put out content with no
ideas and why not because they can
shovel stale garbage into the audience's
mouth and get them to eat it anyway
and if you could do that why bother
cooking a gourmet meal
which takes us to the third point
but i think we carry much of the blame
here
you know we complain that hollywood
never puts out anything worthwhile and
all they do is repeat themselves
and yet we continue to give them our
money and ingest whatever nonsense they
feed us
and i do blame millennials for much of
this
i think as millennials we get
too much blame in general for the state
of society a society that was already
broken before we got here thanks boomers
but for this i give us much of the blame
because we have an insatiable appetite
for what we call nostalgia
and so the studios can churn out
slightly revamped versions of the things
we watched when we were kids and we will
obediently just gobble it all down
but we never stopped to think about the
fact
first of all that so much of our
childhood nostalgia is tied up to
tied to media and and products and
brands we liked
rather than actual real-life human
experiences
and we never worried about the fact that
our appetites and tastes apparently
haven't matured or changed a single bit
since the age of 12.
and so it becomes a vicious self-fueling
cycle we remain in perpetual adolescence
which means hollywood can keep redoing
and rehashing the same films and shows
we enjoyed in our adolescence and the
more we absorb that content
the more we remain in that childish
state
so
there are many people to blame here
including ourselves
which is why disney is cancelled all
these hollywood studios are cancelled
for producing this trek but so are we
for continuing to watch it
and uh
on that self-loathing note we will
end it for the day thanks for watching
thanks for listening have a great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producer is mathis glover
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pablo vadosky the
show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by cherokee heart
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
today on the ben shapiro show the
shipping bottleneck continues as joe
biden ignores reality and blames private
companies inflation continues to spike
while the white house downplays the
problem and hunter biden's email scandal
starts to infect joe that's today on the
bench bureau show